So there is the church and the church is underneath the cross,
right?
So that St Peter's Basilica.
And so there's the cross on the globe on top of the basilica,
and then there's the cross on the uh,
obelisk as well.
And so what that means is that,
and this is where things get insanely complicated,
is that the center is defined by whatever the cross represents.
Now the cross represents a crossing point.
Geographically,
it's,
it's certainly that the cross probably represents the body to some degree,
but then the cross also represents the place of suffering obviously.
And more importantly it,
it represents the place of voluntary suffering.
Transcended.
I'm speaking psychologically,
right?
Not Theologically.
That's what it represents.
And so you might say,
so here's the idea behind putting down the obelisk with the cross and saying
that that's the center.
So that's the thing that everyone's aiming at.
And so the I,
the idea would be,
well,
if you're going to be a member of the group defined by this obelisk,
then what you do is accept your position at the center of suffering voluntarily
and therefore transcend it.
That's the idea.
And that is one hell of an idea.
It really is,
man,
that is a killer idea because it's actually a signal.
It's a really clear signal of psychological health.
You know,
because one of the things you do if you're a clinical psychologist and someone
is paralyzed by fear is what you do is you break their fears down into
relatively manageable bits,
and then you have the voluntarily confront their fears.
And it might also be things that they're disgusted by it say if they have
obsessive compulsive disorder,
but it produces very strong negative emotion,
whatever it is.
And then you have them voluntarily confront whatever it is that produces that
overwhelming negative emotion and that makes them stronger.
That's what happens.
It doesn't make them less afraid.
It makes them more courageous and stronger.
And that is not the same thing.
It's seriously not.
It doesn't decrease the fear.
It increases the courage.
And so that's a mind boggling idea and it's deeper.
You know,
one of the things that's really interesting about these archetypal ideas is
that,
and maybe it's partly because of the hyperlink nature of the Bible,
that's part of it,
but it's not,
the whole thing is that no matter how deep you dig into them,
you'll never get to the bottom.
You know,
you hit a bottom,
you think,
God,
that's so unbelievably profound.
And then if you excavate a little underneath that,
you find something else that's even more profound and you think,
wow,
that's gotta be the bottom.
And then you dig under that.
It's like there's no bottom.
You can just keep digging down while as far as I can tell,
you can keep digging down layer after layer.
And we'll talk a little bit about more,
a little more about what the cross signifies as the center,
because you see what people were trying to figure out is what is it that we need
to unite under,
right?
What's the proper thing to unite under?
I can give you another example.
So in the Mesopotamian societies,
the emperor
who was more or less than an absolute monarch,
he lived inside what was essentially a walled city.
And the god of the Mesopotamians was Martik.
And martech was the figure who had eyes all the way around his head.
And he spoke magic words.
So it was very attentive and very articulate,
and it was mark who went out and confronted the goddess of chaos,
the dragon of chaos and cutter into pieces and made up the world.
Okay?
So you can kind of understand what that means.
So Marta goes beyond the frontier into the place of predatory chaos and
encounters the thing that's terrifying and then make something productive out of
it.
So it's a hero myth.
And,
and Martech is elected to the position of preeminent God by all the other
Mesopotamian gods because he manages that.
So the,
the Martech idea emerges up the holy
dominance hierarchy and hits the Pinnacle and God only knows how long that took.
It would be the amalgamation of many tribes.
And then the,
the what?
The,
the distillation of all the tribal myths to produce this emergent story of what
constitutes top God.
And then the job of the emperor was to act out Marduk.
That's what gave him sovereignty.
So the reason that he was the center around which people organize themselves
wasn't because he was when he was being a proper emperor,
it wasn't because there was something super special about him,
like the power didn't exactly reside in him,
which is a really useful thing to separate.
Right?
You want the power,
which is why it's kind of Nice to have a symbolic monarch.
You get the symbolic power separated from the personality power,
right?
Cause otherwise they get conflated.
That's what happened in Rome.
It's a very,
and it,
and you can see it tending to happen now and then in the u s like with the
Kennedy dynasties and that sort of thing.
So the idea was the emperor had sovereignty as long as he was acting out Marta
properly and going out into the chaos and cutting it into pieces and making
order.
That was his job they used to take about outside the city on the New Year's
festival and strip him of all his emperor garments and humiliate them and then
force him to,
to confess all the ways that year he hadn't been a good Martech,
so he wasn't a good ruler.
And so that was supposed to clue him in and wake him up.
Right?
And then they would ritually reenact the battle of Martech against tie timeout
out the chaos monster using statues.
And then if that all went well,
then the emperor would go back in and the city would be renewed for another
year.
And we still have echoes of that in our New Year's celebration.
Writes the same idea that's echoed down all those,
all those centuries,
thousands of years.
So it says such a staggeringly brilliant idea,
right?
Because so part of the idea is that the thing that sovereign,
so that's the pillar at the center that,
that everyone gathers around is at least in part the thing that courageously
goes out into the unknown and make something useful out of it for the community.
So
that's very,
very smart.
It's very smart.
So this is another example of a center.
So these,
this is the flag,
this is the Union Jack.
And so it's made up of a bunch of crosses,
right?
And so the first cross,
the English cross,
that's the flag of Saint George.
That's the flag of England.
And say,
what does Saint George do?
Slays the Dragon.
Exactly.
Same idea,
right?
So St George,
patron saint of England goes out and slays the dragon and freeze the virgin from
the grip of the Dragon.
Same idea,
right?
So that's the center.
And then the second cross is called,
uh,
a Saltier,
but it's another crucifix.
So it's the cross on which Saint Andrew was crucified.
So it's the same idea.
It's that the center is the center of suffering voluntarily undertaken because
Saint Andrew was a martyr.
And then Saint Patrick is the third cross.
And what did Saint Patrick do in Ireland?
Chased out all the snakes,
right?
So it's the same thing,
And so the flag of Great Britain is the combination of all of these three
crosses that defines the center.
And that's what the flag is.
So that symbolizes all of that.
So that's,
you know,
completely mind boggling.
So when there's more about Saint Patrick too,
so he banishes the snakes after a 40 day fast.
And so that's an illusion to the 40 years that Moses spends in the desert.
And also the 40 days that Christ fast in the New Testament and his walking stick
when he plants it grows into a tree.
So that echos all of the ideas about the center that we just described.
And he also speaks with the ancient Irish ancestors,
which if you remember,
is a characteristic of the shamanic rituals where we're so in the typical
shamonic ritual,
which seems to be elicited by psychedelic use,
the Sharman dissolve down past their bones and then they go up into heaven and
speak with the ancestors,
and then they're introduced into the heavenly kingdom and then the flash is put
back on their bones and they come back and tell everybody what happened.
And that's a repeatable experience,
right?
The shamanic tradition is unbelievably widespread.
So all over Europe,
ancient Europe and Asia,
and perhaps as far down as South America,
right?
It's highly conserved.
And it's out of that tradition in all likelihood that our religious idiation
emerged.
So,
and you can see echoes of that here.